you claim that there's a couple of
things that you can't cook coffee coffee
and toast bread I set bread on fire
constantly and consistently I care about
what I can see in front of me so why
can't you make coffee to that I don't
know and I think that John sabotages me
when he leaves town I really do
and he's going away tonight and I
guarantee you buddy all morning it'll
look like kiss or mud right and it'll
suck and he will have somehow
strategically but it's on something but
isn't it all like you scoop it out and
you put it on the thing it's supposed to
grinded and fill it listen I push the
button and it works it doesn't work
every time he's not there it doesn't
work I make toast and I don't I put it
in the toaster and I watch it and if it
starts to get a little too Brown I stop
I should come on your show and cook
toast in my defense yes I'm usually
making toast for multiple people which
you have to then put on a tray that's
true
and broil so you have to put it under a
flame in the oven to get a large amount
of buns or bread charred or you have to
do it one at a time over an open flame
or you have to stand at the toaster for
like half an hour I don't have the time
isn't it funny so when I put it in the
oven it catches fire on my show I
legitimately have done an open fire and
you're out red are you cooking over wood
what you do know if you have it if you
have a gas stove a little flame comes up
on isn't it funny
but even if it's the bright red like bar
thing in the electric oven I think I'll
set it on fire